Y hablamos por supuesto de revista de
prensa de nuestro programa matinal de
France 24 Marta Moya abrimos nuestra
revista de prensa repasando brevemente
los deportes no esta vez de la prensa
Argentina es autista así como de la
prensa gráfica tras la sorpresiva
derrota del día de ayer de Argentina que
todavía Pues en muchos no lo han
superado si Raúl buenos días vamos a
empezar con la nación de Argentina que
titula un titular muy categórico no
derrumbe y desafío y muestra la cara del
capitán de Leo Messi cabizbajo y con las
manos en la cara no creo que esta sea
una muy buena noticia para esos
argentinos te acuerdas que viajaron
desde Sudáfrica acatar en bicicleta para
ver a Messi levantar la copa Todavía
queda mucho pero pues el Debut no fue
muy alentador titula la canción que esta
fue una histórica derrota ante Arabia
Saudita y que obliga a una rápida
reacción para evitarla eliminación del
conjunto albiceleste nadie se lo
esperaba dice la sobre todo después de
que argentina se adelantará en el
marcador Qué dice río negro el río negro
este periódico de la Patagonia Argentina
titula nadie lo vio venir y utiliza la
misma foto de Leo Messi con porque claro
este conjunto tiene muchas expectativas
para ganar al menos mucho hype y Porque
además el último mundial
exactamente
mundial con Argentina Mejor dicho en
palabras del propio Messi pidió
confianza a la afición y sostiene este
periódico río negro que este es un hoy
fue un escenario impensado que deja al
equipo sin margen de error Bueno vamos
ahora con el news y este es un titular
Raúl que a mí me ha dejado fascinada
porque hace como una frase atribuida a
evita perón Don Cry for me Argentina que
después se convirtió en un éxito musical
este periódico Saudita sostiene no que
Arabia Saudita gesto ese shock en Qatar
tras vencer a uno de los equipos
favoritos y que es la primera vez que un
equipo árabe o asiático gana al dos
veces campeón del mundo en estas fases
del Campeonato vamos ahora
sacamos una viñeta del libanés en la que
bueno se ve a esta Palmera que es un
emblema Nacional de Arabia Saudita
golpeando con una bota de fútbol a una
esos soles de la bandera Argentina que
están desdibujados Bueno y qué dice
destaca que el rey de Arabia Saudita
precisamente decretó feriado nacional
tras El Triunfo de la selección contra
Argentina no la casa salman decidió que
este miércoles los empleados públicos y
privados estén de fiesta y Esto fue
Bueno atribuido después de que lo así lo
sugiriera el príncipe heredero Bin
salman y bueno ayer hubo festejos
improvisados en muchas ciudades y Arabia
Saudita concretamente los festejos en la
capital en riad duraron hasta altas
horas de la madrugada seguimos con
noticias relacionadas al Marta y vamos
con un artículo británico del medio
británico de Garden Por qué Porque
alerta las preocupaciones de la
selección iraní que pueda sufrir
represalias por no entonar su Himno
Nacional esto a la previa de el partido
jugado un tema que también repasa la
prensa gráfica empezamos entonces con de
guardia Sí y el dentitud la crece el
temor a que los jugadores de Irán sufran
represalias por no cantar el himno
nacional concretamente cita las palabras
del presidente del Consejo de la ciudad
de Teherán que sostiene que no se va a
permitir que nadie insulte nuestro himno
y nuestra bandera se espera que haya
represalias contra los jugadores si en
los partidos que le quedan Por jugar a
Irán al menos en esta fase de grupos no
entonan este himno no recordemos que el
equipo guardó silencio durante el himno
nacional y que además no celebró los
goles de la derrota Eso sí seis a dos
contra Inglaterra el otro día y esto se
atribuyó que estaban de lado no de las
protestas que se están sucediendo en el
país tras la muerte de maxameni en
septiembre además dice este artículo de
The Guardian que un diputado conservador
del kurdistán dijo que el equipo
nacional se debería sustituir por
completo por jóvenes fieles y
revolucionarios que estén dispuestos a
cantar el himno los medios locales
iraníes no se han pronunciado al
respecto de esta cuestión pero las
fuerzas de seguridad sí que descargaron
esa ira contra los protestantes en Irán
y bueno que que alentaba no y que
celebraba la victoria de Inglaterra y
gritaban muerte al dictador
concretamente cita un ejemplo de un
restaurante en Teherán que apoyó a
Inglaterra y el régimen iraní cerró ese
restaurante y lo precinto a finales de
septiembre el equipo de Irán ya había
vestido de negro en un partido amistoso
contra senegal para esconder esos
colores de la bandera es que no hay
mucho que celebrar Marta en un país
situación también un mundial atípico no
muchas cosas que están pasando alrededor
del mundo en medio de esta fiesta
futbolística y pues de toda la polémica
en torno a Qatar vamos ahora con the
time siguiendo este tema Sí destacamos
una viñeta de Peter Brooks que hace como
una crítica explícita no a estos
jugadores y al sobre todo al régimen que
puede instalar represalias contra los
jugadores de la selección en la que se
vea los líderes no del régimen iraní con
látigos con cuerdas y con metralletas
cantando en un tono amenazante me
gustaría enseñar a nuestro equipo a
cantar en perfecta armonía vamos
nuevamente con movement Sí destacamos
también una viñeta del cartoon bookman
en la que se ve a un jugador de la
selección iraní cortándose la lengua
para no cantar el himno nacional
haciendo un paralelismo también cuando
las mujeres iraníes empezaron en esas
primeras semanas de protesta a cortarse
el cabello tras la muerte bajo custodia
policial de masa a mini siguiendo en
Irán vamos con el medio independiente
algunos de los periodistas deportivos
iraníes fueron detenidos en el marco de
estas protestas que continúan también
entre rejas Sí y lo titula así
periodistas deportivos iraníes
arrestados antes de la copa del mundo
continúan encarcelados concretamente se
refiere a tres periodistas deportivos y
a un reportero gráfico que continúan en
prisiones después de haber sido
detenidos entre septiembre y octubre Al
Calor de estas protestas No unos están
en prisión preventiva otros se les ha
negado el derecho a tener a un abogado y
otros ni siquiera han sido informados de
los motivos por los que fueron
arrestados entre ellos está Neil lufar
hamedi que es una periodista deportiva
que no puede ver a su familia desde
finales de septiembre fue arrestada en
su casa y además el régimen iraní la
acusa de atentar contra la seguridad
nacional y de ser una agente extranjera
porque ella misma publicó la primera
foto de marsha mini en el hospital
Después de ser detenida por la policía
de la moral además sostiene este
artículo del que tanto la sociedad de
periodistas como escritores no han
tomado de momento ninguna medida al
respecto para pedir responsabilidades
por la detención de sus colegas claro
Marta como siempre Gracias por toda la
información de esta revista de prensa
mañana Por supuesto con más mañana